did when you do that for because you're
not wearing green and I am and it's
Saint Eddie I am wearing green have you
seen my underwear no please don't so
yeah I honor to st. Patty's Day yeah we
thought we'd present a bunch of green
stuff but we're not talking about the
color green we're talking about actually
like yeah made from recycled materials
eco-friendly stuff why not right yeah
green beer green gear ok I've noticing
them wearing a green wetsuit we're on
the office on fridays i have been well
you you surf right I do I just started
to start a surfing and then you've also
just kind of like been wearing it around
well yeah yeah yeah I mean you want to
get really into the feel of things I
kingdom and if the reality of this
wetsuit is it's the most comfortable
most flexible wetsuit I've ever had so
it's so comfortable you kind of just
don't want to take it off so instead of
using like petroleum-based neoprene I
touch your wet suit they use a limestone
base via cream which is this invention
in Japan basically billabong took that
neoprene and then on top of it they
basically and all this stuff they've
worked out using ninety percent recycled
polyester to create this like super
flexible fabric what do you have for us
whoa us I got this what is that
so this solar panel on the back can be
used to charge up a wide variety of
consumer electronics including your
laptop it actually has a backup battery
charger on it that converts voltage then
it comes with all these adapters right
here you got the the ipod there you
gotta set for cell phone right USB I
mean it seems kind of ridiculous that we
don't have like a universal charger at
this point doesn't it it does but you
know how companies like the proprietary
chargers oh but look at this the
magnetic charger for Maya that's pretty
cool that's pretty nice very smart so I
mean is this thing like a thousand
dollars it's only five hundred dollars
the idea of charging if your laptops
pretty awesome but you work at the beach
it's perfect it's perfect but you live
in a cave yeah not so much yeah but then
you're kind of just bummed out anyways
cuz you indicate what's this thing oh
dude this is the motorola w 2 33 it's a
phone that's a hate out of recycled
bottles that's cool yeah not really it
kind of sucks as a photo of the phone so
it's terrible yeah a lot of junk in your
solar trunk alright so I'm done with
this what do you got uh well I have the
oh my god yeah i know i have this nature
milk compost you are so strong to be
lifting this thing up all by yourself
it's only 17 pounds it only weighs 7
that are only weighs 17 pounds din it
stopped talking to me is freaking it out
essentially you could compost in your
apartment with it and you can do like up
to a hundred and twenty pounds of
compost in like us essentially a few
weeks talk about mulch ado about nothing
that's terrible if you don't have a
house you got your compost of the
backyard so I'm where are you gonna do
it you're gonna in your kitchen exactly
so I mean like we tested this out and in
our kitchen why are we being testing
this out in the last couple days yeah we
had to go out to the park across the
street did dirt yeah yeah scoop up some
dirty cuz we're journalists were good
scooping up dirt exactly it's actually
kind of the easiest composting like I've
ever had to do so you basically just
open it up throw on your starter soil
you throw in these like little sawdust
oh they're pellets right yeah which are
basically breath mints for compost
rights or doesn't reek so it cuts down
on the smell and then additionally like
it sort of allows the chemical reactions
to take place between the cultures from
the soil and then the food which you
then add on right afterwards it's very
important that you cut your food into
four
inch chunks because if you don't it can
clog the machine yeah the engine rotates
it around and then you're supposed to
let it sit for a week which we haven't
really done yet all right but wait wait
but in a week do you know check back and
it should we should have the start of a
really really healthy nitrogen-rich yes
oh yeah just for plant things but
Stephen one word of advice what should
you not do when the machine is working
do not do not open the top do you know
why how much is how much is cost
I do